this is so weird it's drew's birthday
i'm savannah guthrie i'm here to
celebrate drew oh just david letterman
swinging by to shock drew i don't think
surprise is the word i think it's shock
that moment well i i'm delighted to be
here and i heard the conversation about
do you like surprises do you not like
surprises oh i do like surprises i'm on
the other end of a surprise i went to
australia i was surprised they surprised
and i just thought
wait a minute i hate
surprises geez i just hate them and i
kept saying she has to know this woman
is a seasoned show business veteran
in front of the camera behind the camera
in her office anywhere you want to put
her she has to know this is going on and
and then you come out here and you're
crying and that was so touching and very
sweet of you thank you i'm just so
honored that you showed up oh please i
mean it i because
um i feel even weird saying up for me
i'm just so happy to see you as an old
friend it's been a long time yeah you
were saying 20 years it's at least 20
years i think i don't know
it's um
i remember i used to bring you um
laserdiscs
for the commercial break i would bring
you like cocktails beauty and the beast
because i knew that you were a big old
yeah yeah and
i ended up hosting turner classic movies
the essentials we presented 90 movies
robert osborne and i and i just loved
old films and i thought that's a great
weigh-in for me and dave yeah but well
i've seen every old movie ever made i
love old movies i mean i come from old
movies let me ask you a question i was
trying to put together the the barrymore
family
and i came across john
drew barrymore great grandfather great
grandfather and i thought dumbbell
that's where the drew comes from that's
exactly right georgiana drew is my
great-grandmother and john drew
is my great grandfather and they had
john lionel and ethel and they were big
famous john lionel and ethel wow in one
family that's remarkable i know then you
of course
thank you now were your daughters are
they interested in this
i think
they're interested i've gone an extreme
i've like kept them on the sidelines
which is
you know sort of part my own personal
baggage yeah i saw them out there on the
sidelines
they're there
but i was like you know what let me just
get you set up
and prepared
for life
before i throw you into this
and if and when they're ready and i have
no idea when that will be it will just
be a feeling and a level of maturity and
a moment
and then i'm like whatever you want to
do i'll support it and i'm excited for
them to like
be on the scene i'm excited for whatever
their journey was i just didn't want
them to be like why did you put us in
this
can't it have been an elective well
that's right that's a good point and as
we all know uh sadly sometimes the
pedigree the background the upbringing
the early years
no guarantee it's going to work out for
you
irrespective of the pursuit i think
you know i'm in a big pool of cliches of
how hard it is to go into this business
and have all access to everything and
not be a kid and just have everything so
upside down it doesn't seem like a lot
of us make it out uh
very well
let me interrupt here and i i know it's
not my show to produce but how great
would this be
if it was really a surprise for somebody
guthrie
ladies and
you gentlemen in fact
i think we should uh roll a certain clip
get off the furniture
what is going on would you like me to do
a dance for you
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my goodness that happened
[Applause]
dave do you remember that anything about
that yeah i'll tell you honestly
no i forgot all about it yes of course i
remember and at the time
uh uh i used to watch old movies uh
blackboard jungle glen ford and what
happens is the juvenile delinquent
teenagers take over the classroom and
they're up on glenn ford's desk and
they're going to beat him up and so uh
drew is there
i love the high paul
and then and then she climbs up on the
desk and i i thought to myself oh no
i've lost control of the class
and and then my next thought was i think
i think i'm probably going to get kicked
and then everything change you know like
in the wizard of oz when it goes from
black and white to color
that's what it was like like that was
like when you lost your innocence
[Laughter]
or something sad but true yes that's
exactly how it was the moment yeah
i had
no plan
of doing that it was one of those
moments in my life where i felt like
a magnet was pulling me uh and it was
all very playful and well intended
and i just had no idea where it was
going i couldn't almost believe it was
happening i think a little bit i was on
the ride too wondering what was going to
happen next
and
you taught me in that moment
how
to
be as a human being because
i was shocked and i almost was like
should i be embarrassed did i do
something bad am i in trouble
and i knew in that moment that with one
turn you could have gone
why did you do that
what's what's wrong with you
and instead
you
had that smile
and you said to everyone this moment is
okay
and i thought i will treat people i will
handle i will be the conductor for the
rest of my life to see
when spontaneity happens or something
is going on
[Laughter]
oh my god that was the moment oh my god
i hope that i can have the man dave is
right now and just let something
innocent and spontaneous be innocent and
spontaneous well i recognized it
immediately as being unique
it had
it had not happened prior to me has not
happened since to me
and later i was thinking
oh geez now what if she goes and does
this on leno's show
then i'll really be upset
well with all dudes but it was it was
kind of a connection for us throughout
our the rest of our existence here i
i felt um you compelled me in a moment
to take a risk and you allowed it to be
paid off with kindness
and reciprocity and goodness and humor
which is my ultimate
honestly i think that's the greatest
award and reward that people can give
each other later we were of course
married
we went to a church last stop got
married look at me i'm like i think
you're so cute yeah i did i i've had a
crush on you forever we were happy for
another 20 minutes yeah that's right i
liked the normal marriage drew was on
your show 20 times that's 20 times
remarkable well again yes absolutely and
and this is why
um all
credit to you because
in the world of show business you have
you have two things you have show
business friendships which are not
really friendships and then you have
actual friendships and i considered
our relationship to be a true friendship
thank you i um
i was not there for shock value i was
there to share a moment with you that
took on a little bit of a life of its
own but my heart was so well intended
towards you
now let's talk about the the
circumstance now are you enjoying this
part of your life um
i just feel like when i wake up in the
morning i wake up to savannah
and gail i go to sleep to people like
you and you know i think of a jimmy
fallon who's like family
and
you guys are who
jumpstart and close out our days and
that's why i felt so privileged to step
into a role that has been so
important to me as a citizen and a human
being walking around
you are literally telling people it's
okay to start their day here's how it's
going to go here's some optimism here's
some news and revision and you would say
you got through the day
i'm going to put you to bed
congratulations right now you're allowed
to leave
this is a great way for you to look at
it because it's true the landscape
in the early morning uh middle of the
day or whenever we see you uh several
other people have helped along the way
have been very beneficial oprah was
fantastic and oh my god regis do you
remember regionals i loved reefs oh my
god oh we all love packages
dave how do you like being a guest by
the way regis
no well he's on somewhere you know he's
fine
he will live forever in a lot of ways so
dave do you like being a guest no no i'm
very uncomfortable about it although i'm
very pleased about the zoomer thing and
i mentioned that was my idea do i can i
talk a lot of places don't want me to
talk
out here it's interesting about life
you you learn things over that you
already learned and then you you forget
because
you're drawn toward the mundane
so you you can't be sucked into the
the reality the drama and the ugliness
that can be provided by life so you're
drawn toward the mundane and you learn
these lessons again and again and
because of the pandemic
you know people who have had it and
perhaps died i know people who have died
same same with all of us we're looking
at a half a million people
i don't know how many wars that is but a
half a million
stunning that we're living with every
day so i think
uh humanity is temporary
and we all know that and because it's
temporary
we need each other we more more than
ever when you realize it's temporary
need each other so i'm trying to be
outgoing and pleasant and helpful
whenever i can
this morning
i'm driving here in new york city
and i'm driving the car there's people
parked on this side of the street people
parked on that side of the street and
ahead of me in my lane is a guy with his
blinkers so i'm not going anywhere now
there's a car to the right of me that's
now
is all of a sudden it's daytona and
she's forcing
her and i got nowhere to go
so i thought okay okay normally i would
have been upset you can't help but be
upset about this
so i inched up and i rolled down the
window and i said roll down your window
and i said i'm sorry i there's a car
you can't there's nowhere for you to go
here
i'll help just tell me what you're what
you're doing and i'll help i'll anything
and she's staring at me as though i'm
invisible
and she's staring at me and finally she
says yeah well i really appreciate your
sarcastic attitude
and i thought well there you go i'm i'm
trying to help humanity
you know what you helped humanity
because you came and you just absolutely
dazzled and moved your old friend drew
yes that's her birthday that's
satisfying but i want this woman
okay if if she hears about this i wasn't
being sarcastic no but i was oh yeah i
know
i guess you can't uh outrun your past i
don't know
well you did help humanity for what was
it 30 years i mean i always talk about
both of your shows as such like
my training ground my inspiration what i
needed in
life when i would see you out in your
trench coat man in the field i
i love you both so much i honestly live
to make you proud i mean that with all
of my heart i can't believe i get to
call you guys my friends
is she going to be all right
we love you so much and you know what
drew i got to say thank you for bringing
us together i never got to meet dave
letterman savannah guthrie i said oh
yeah i know savannah and i realized no
we never did no but we're probably going
to text all the time now or zoom oh yeah
yeah you saw how much trouble i had with
the zoomer dave thank you so much
uh they're wrapping me up you know about
the wrap up you remember that right i
ignored that like a stop sign oh
i love that i don't know what you're
trying to savannah's going to a
commercial they're going to tell me c
like i know i know but
it's really well it meant a lot
okay
let me ask you this is the couch paid
for
yeah but do you want it kind of like
it's yours
anything you want dave god bless you
thank you very much for letting me be a
part of this oh thank you so much yeah i
think
you saw how i felt it's hard to come
come to my funeral
in a hundred years